alright I'm back back with a surgically
repaired Achilles so I'm good as new
well not really good as new I've got a
six to eight month recovery process
which is kind of depressing because
that's a long time but you know I'm on
the road to recovery which which is nice
one note about the surgery though
because you know the great thing may be
the number one benefit of of having kids
is that you they keep you humble I think
that's and here's a wonderful example of
that from after I got back from the
surgery so I got home on Wednesday was
an outpatient thing so got home from the
from the operation I'm hobbling inside
feeling not very good you know because I
still have the effects of the the
anesthesia and I'm feeling nauseous from
that and I'm it's it hurts you know
because I just got surgery and so I got
to get upstairs to my bed which is where
I'm gonna end up spending the next like
48 hours and the only way that I can get
up to the bed in that condition is to
crawl so I'm crawling up the steps to
get to my room and my my six-year-old
daughter comes in and she sees me
crawling up the steps and she starts
laughing hysterically at this sight of
her dad crawling up the steps and she's
gone oh my gosh look at daddy's Krung
and then and then yeah she calls to her
brothers in the next room say hey come
here look at this daddy he's crawling
he's like a dog yeah like a dog come
look look look at this and then they're
both just standing there as I'm crawling
up the steps you know in in pain
grimacing and they're just laughing this
is a funniest thing they'd ever seen in
their life and so anyway I'm gonna put
them in sensitivity training for that
because you just it is not PC to laugh
at a [ __ ] as he crawls up the steps I
mean I get it but still actually what I
actually I explained to them that if you
want to laugh at the misfortunes of
others you need to do it like an adult
and that means waiting until they leave
the room and then you laugh at them so
that's just it's an important life
lesson alright um a lot to cover as I
play catch-up here but first before we
get to all that a word from our friends
at noon you know getting getting in
shape isn't just about losing weight
it's it's about learning healthier
habits you know so that's where that's
where it really
sticks that's where you get the
lifestyle change and it's also about
feeling better about yourself whether
that's more stamina to keep up with with
you know your kids and your busy life or
being more in tune with your body's
needs practicing better self-care
whatever it is what if you could use
just one program for all of that for all
your health and weight loss needs no
more hunting for training apps and
workouts calorie trackers meal plans all
that stuff what if you get it all under
one roof so to speak and that's where
noon comes in the great thing about noon
is that it works no matter your
situation your age whatever it is you
know it works for you I know for my
specific situation now that with my
injury I'm looking for something that
will keep me healthy keep my energy up
keep me feeling good keep me from from
gaining 50 pounds as I'm laying around
the couch even though I can't do all the
things that I normally physically would
do and Noom is great for that as well so
Noom is a habit changing solution that
helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses it's based in
psychology so Noom teaches you why you
do the things you do and it arms you
with the tools to break the bad habits
and to replace them with good habits
that's the name of the game you don't
have to change it all in one day small
steps make big progress so sign up for
your trial today your trial at noon noon
calm okay that's N oom calm slash Walsh
what do you have to lose you really
don't have anything to lose except for
except for the weight you want to lose
visit Noom comm slash Walsh to start
your trial today that's Noom comm slash
Walsh the last weight loss program that
you'll ever need
all right where where do we start okay
well let's let's start with this you
know Twitter announced last week that
they're going to have a zero-tolerance
policy for child sexual exploitation
which which is which is good if they
actually followed that their own their
own policy which they don't because on
almost the exact same day that they
announced this they they reasserted this
policy a vice posted a video which I'll
play for in a minute play for you in a
minute but this video
both portrays and glorifies child sexual
sexual exploitation and yet it has been
allowed to remain on Twitter's platform
even though I know a bunch of people
reported it I reported it but no
response from from from Twitter and it
still remains the vice video as you'll
see in a second here is a kind of fun
and whimsical look at the quote
community of young boys who dress in
women's clothing and dance for the
perverted entertainment of adults it is
disturbing I'll warn you but I think
it's important that you see what we're
talking about so here's here's some of
that video
[Music]
drag kids is a new documentary directed
by Megan Wenberg that follows for drag
obsessed kids from different cities just
so cute thank you not quite sure I'm
going to a drag branch to meet with the
young performers and ask them about the
community that they found with their
fellow drag kids you just fall in love
with each of them for so many different
reasons cuz they're all the fact that
these kids are brave enough to do
something that is so different hopefully
you would give out up your courage to
fight so vice proudly announces that
these children are the the next
generation of drag queens but they're
not really a part of the next generation
there they are the current generation
they're the current crop I guess you
might say of a new type of quote drag
performer I should say well I say new
but really just new in the West in
Western civilization this is new but if
you go over in places like Afghanistan
it's this is this has been customary for
a long time very customary to have to
have young boys and female attire dance
for the pleasure of grown men and in
Afghanistan you know the boys will be
brought out they'll dance for the for
the for the grown men and then the boys
often time will be brought somewhere and
sexually abused so it's a very similar
sort of thing we have adopted a similar
custom but we have done it under the
guise of progressivism in Afghanistan
it's you know it's it's it's always very
interesting to see how you've got these
fundamentalist Muslims and this is what
they're doing and then you've got
progressives in our country it's
interesting to see how often these two
ideologies mirror each other and this is
just one area where they do the left if
you haven't noticed has become
increasingly obsessed with dressing boys
up like girls and parading them around
literally parading them around in some
cases like when the LA Pride Parade last
week they had a seven-year-old boy
strutting in high heels strutting is the
word that the media used when describing
in a celebratory fashion describing this
boy seven-year-old boy in high heels and
a skirt at the front of the LA Pride
Parade and you know if you think I'm
joking about the left's obsession with
this well here is another video this
one's from Huffington Post this one was
also posted in the last couple of days
also ended up on Twitter and has
remained there so these are two videos
one from vice and one from huffington
post about about drag kids here's the
huffington post one I was born in
fragment in the year 2007 gay pride
means self-expression hi I'm a drag Kim
and I live in York City and Amon LGBTQ
activist and advocate I discovered that
I wanted to drag when it was the first
episode of RuPaul's Drag Race when I was
2 then I moved on to like little dresses
then I moved on to making outfits I've
got my 300 as I was like as I'm the
queen Betty Johnson comes egg our songs
Jean Paul Gautier the club kid their
fashion and the makeup not the bad
things the Blitz kids of London if you
want to drag to start off with a little
wig and some lip gloss and a little like
t-shirt and that little skirt and some
peel or thinker's whatever you're gonna
be addressing no matter what so you see
that the left really really really wants
to push this stuff it's it's become like
a white weekly occurrence or more than
that they want little boys to dress like
girls they really want and and what you
find is that little attempt is made
anymore to hide the sexual nature of the
drag kid phenomenon now if you confront
the left
about this directly of course they're
gonna say Oh what are you talking about
oh there's nothing sexual about this
yeah yeah I mean you've got little boys
and dresses dancing for grown men but
that's a there's nothing else you're the
one something wrong with you that you
would think of as sexual so that's how
they'll respond if you confront them
about it directly but then when you look
at what they're actually doing it has
become more and more sexual you may
remember for instance the quote drag kid
who posed with a naked man and that
picture was posted on Instagram a couple
of months ago now I'm not gonna put that
picture up for you it's out there if you
feel like confirming what I'm talking
about here I would recommend that you
don't just you don't subject yourself to
that but an adult drag queen posed naked
with a nine or ten-year-old boy who was
dressed in women's clothing and that was
put on Instagram and as far as I know
allowed to stay there and then there was
the drag kid who danced at a gay bar
recently while men tossed money at him
this should really put into perspective
for those still oblivious enough to
think that things like the drag queen
story hours popping up at libraries
across the country are just a bit of
harmless fun you know occasionally I'll
even talk to us I'll come across a
conservative who will say you know it's
not a big deal I mean if this is how
people want to dress what's the big deal
well this is why it's a big deal because
it's part of an agenda these are not
isolated instance in incidents I mean
hundreds of libraries have hosted these
events where they bring children and
cross-dressing men together and there is
of course no practical reason why if you
want to read a book to children why you
would need to dress in women's clothing
first if you're a man and there's no
practical reason or coherent reason why
a library if they want to have a story
time which is great for a libraries to
have story times my my wife brings our
kids to library story times all the time
but they're just story times okay it's
not drag queens it's just the librarian
is sitting there reading a book to the
kids great there's no reason
a man dressed up like a woman from a Tim
Burton movie which is how all drag
queens dress for some reason there's no
reason why you need someone like that
reading the story the decision to add
that rather grotesque element into the
equation is purposeful and the purpose
is to get children boys especially
accustomed to the idea of cross-dressing
so the the sexual exploiters of children
want to ensure that there is going to be
a constantly refreshed supply of well
they call them baka boys in Afghanistan
but we call them drag queens or drag
drag quick kids the left wants to make
sure that there's a constantly refreshed
supply of drag quids kids so follow the
trajectory and it's not hard to see
where we go next right 10 years ago
there was no such thing as drag kids or
drag queens or there was or drag queens
story ours at least yeah a drag shows
your drag queens but the idea of
bringing them into a library that didn't
exist 10 years ago drag kids that didn't
exist and in fact 10 years ago if you
had looked in your crystal ball and
predicted that we would end up in this
spot leftist would have laughed at you
and called you a paranoid lunatic they
would have said will you talk about yeah
we're gonna have drag queens coming to
libraries to read stories the kids what
do you see you're insane right come on
you're being ridiculous but now that's
utterly commonplace yet leftist will
still insist that even though grown men
and dresses like to hang out with little
children at libraries and adults like to
go to gay bars to watch boys dance
around in skirts and high heels they'll
still say that there's nothing sexual
about it if you ask them directly but 10
years from now if you follow the
trajectory 10 years from now or maybe
sooner I think what's gonna happen is
they're going to admit that it is sexual
but they'll insist that there's nothing
wrong with a young boy and a grown man
getting together so long as it's
consensual
you don't need to be Nostradamus to
to see the next step okay this is not
some sort of prophecy that I'm offering
here this is just observing where we are
where we were ten years ago and you just
follow the line I mean we're on a train
look at the track and you can see where
it's going it said there's no there's no
mystery okay there's no mystery about
where a train is headed because it's on
a track and it's the same for our
culture right now that is why I left ISM
is an active threat to our children and
this is why we cannot compromise with it
or seek common ground you know or try to
understand where it's coming from
what kind of common ground can a sane
and moral person find with the sorts of
people who think it's acceptable had to
have a ten year old boy
perform at a gay bar I mean me as a
normal person
I just I cannot fathom what area of
agreement I could possibly find with a
person like that we could not be further
apart in every conceivable way and
what's more is I don't want to find
common ground with them I don't want to
compromise I don't want to get along
with them with these people who are
doing this to kids I don't want to hold
hands with them and you know skip
merrily in to a better tomorrow I don't
want to do that because this is an evil
ideology through and through and it has
to be destroyed
defeated that has to be our our
objective okay we defeat it or else we
just sit back and watch as our children
are destroyed by it those are our
choices and it really is as simple as
that
I think it's a choice now between
leftism and our children you can't
really have both
all right let's live in the mood a
little bit and talk about Democrats
humiliating themselves that's kind of
it's always a fun you know it's a fun
way to to pass the time so first there's
this alleged presidential candidate
Eric's wall well who is polling at 0%
last I checked he gave a speech over the
weekend and and I almost feel bad for
him for laughing at them for this but
it's especially as someone who does
public speaking myself I feel like
there's some bad karma laughing at
someone in a situation like this but I
can't help myself
so Eric's well well he went hard for the
applause line and he didn't land and
watch this but I will always be real
with you I will be bold
without the bold my wife and I we fight
insurance companies I'll be bold without
the bull so the problem is that he first
of all was a bad line I mean what do you
Howard I don't even know what that line
means bold without the bull and
especially at a if you're a politician
and you're talking to the kind of
audience that would show up to hear a
politician speak well then it should be
really easy to land an applause line you
know I mean almost anything could be an
applause line it's so so to to fumble it
like that it's pretty impressive but the
line made no sense and the problem is
when you go for the applause line and
you don't get the apply it you got to
move on quickly so I think when swells a
little bit more seasoned he'll know that
you know you go for the applause you
wait like just half a beat like half a
second and if you don't hear that
applause starting you just keep going so
that maybe nobody will notice that you
were expecting applause there so there's
rxy well meanwhile Kirsten Gillibrand
was that I think a gay bars I think in
gay bar in Iowa because this is Pride
Month I'm not sure if you've heard that
yet I'm not sure if that's been beaten
into your into your head with a hammer
enough yet but it is pride month if you
didn't know so Gillibrand was at a gay
bar for Pride Month and this happened
[Music]
yes
she actually shouted gay rights at the
end there she she she literally at a gay
she went to a gay bar and shouted gay
rights I mean that's actually what
happened this isn't even pandering I
mean this is beyond this is uber
pandering this is this is like the the
Platonic ideal of pandering this is
someone came up with the word pandering
centuries ago and that word has been
floating around out there in the ether
for waiting for its most perfect
physical manifestation and in and and
that's what this is here it is here it
is in the form of a Democratic
presidential candidate wearing a rainbow
love is brave t-shirt at a gay bar
during Pride Month shouting gay rights
the only thing more pandering than that
would be I mean I can't even think of
anything I I can't think of anything
that is that's it that is this is the
ultimate this is a level of pandering
that all other pandering has been
reaching for but could never attain I
mean it's just it's it's it's impressive
now going down the list here Joe Biden
Joe Biden also humiliated himself last
week but I think humiliated himself in a
deeper more shameful kind of way Biden
is taking a dive in the polls after
reversing his position on the Hyde
Amendment now you've probably heard
about that last week but just to recap
Biden has for decades supported the Hyde
Amendment and when I say for decades
when Biden's been in politics for you
know about 600 years I think so that's a
long time you know for pretty much his
entire career he is supported the Hyde
Amendment
which bans the taxpayer funding of
abortion but now after decades of
supporting it at the age of 76 he has
had an epiphany
you know the clouds opened up and and he
realized after all this time that oh you
know actually yeah wewe should force the
taxpayers to fund abortion and reports
that I have read have indicated that
Alyssa Milano is the person who helped
to convince him to change his position
he was talked out of a position that
he's held for like 40 years because the
girl from a show from that show from the
CW talked him out of it now that's this
is evidence either that Joe Biden is
losing his mind or that he is a gutless
coward maybe both
I think I'm going with both just a
couple of things though about the the
Hyde Amendment and the controversy
surrounding it number one about the Hyde
Amendment itself it bares keeping in
mind that the Hyde Amendment bans the
direct funding of abortion with tax
money which is good I mean it's good to
bed of course but we should also
remember that we do already indirectly
fund abortion to the tune of five
hundred million dollars a year we give
five hundred million dollars a year to
Planned Parenthood which is an
organization that performs three hundred
and thirty thousand abortions a year
itself now that money does not go
directly to abortions but money is
fungible which means that if we give
them five hundred million dollars a year
to do other stuff then they can take the
money that would have gone to that you
know their existing money that would
have gone to that other stuff has now
been freed up so that it can go to
abortion so we have in effect funded
abortions by giving five hundred million
dollars a year to to to Planned
Parenthood it's kind of like you know if
you know that I'm a heroin addict and I
ask you to borrow 20 bucks and then I
take your 20 and I put
in my wallet with another 20 that I
already had and then I used $20 so let's
say you're 20 to buy lunch and then I
used the other 20 to buy heroin well you
have in essence for all intents and
purposes you have funded the heroin
purchase by freeing up my existing money
you know for that purpose so you see in
other words if I got 20 in the wallet
and I put another 20 in there it doesn't
really make a difference which 20 I use
to do which thing the fact is now I've
got 40 bucks which I can split between
the heroin and lunch right so that's
that's the way that goes with with
Planned Parenthood so we shouldn't feel
you know this false sense of security
from the Hyde Amendment where we say oh
yeah we got the height of at least we're
not funding abortion we are funding
abortions in effect number two is it
surprising that Biden caved on this
issue well no it's not at all because as
I've said many times abortion is the
central issue for the left it is the
foundational issue you know to be
pro-abortion is to say I am God what I
want goes what I say is right is right
what's good for me is good my truth is
truth you know that's that's it's
relativism that's what that's what the
pro-abortion movement is based on and
that's what the left is is based on it's
founded in you cannot be a leftist
anymore and you certainly cannot be a
Democrat on the national stage without
professing that doctrine that doctrine
of relativism and narcissism just like
you can't be a Christian without
professing the doctrine of Christ's
divinity and in both cases that
profession has to be absolute and
unquestioned and without hesitation and
without reservation or qualification
that's the way
doctrine works now theoretically you can
profess the pro-abortion doctrine
without believing that it should be free
without believing that the taxpayer
should fund it necessarily but if you
fail to support free abortions that's
gonna make left as suspicious
they're gonna say okay now wait a minute
do you really worship at the altar of
baby murder or not because you say you
do yet you you don't want to fund them
and you don't want them to be free and
then you know that the leftists are
gonna say well it's it why why should we
go why should we support you when we've
got this person over here who is far
more invested in in this sacrament so
this is quite literally the deal with
the devil that any modern Democrat must
be prepared to make and if there is a
Democrat right now who's running for
president who's on the national stage
that means that they have made that deal
or they are prepared to make it ah now
this I think will clarify things a
little bit to understand why the left
supports abortion it's helpful to know
what their arguments are and we've
talked a lot about what the what the
pro-abortion arguments are such as they
are or what the argument I guess I
should say what the argument singular is
because you know the arguments the
arguments they present the things they
say the talking points that they put out
there to justify abortion but most of
those are not real arguments they're
just smokescreens to cover the real
motivation the real argument and that's
you know the real motivation the real
argument was just helpfully expressed
recently by a feminist by the name of
Sophie Lewis who is the author of a book
called full surrogacy now feminism
against family feminism against family
it's a very revealing but kind of
redundant title and she had she also had
some revealing things to say about
abortion
in an interview I guess she was talking
about the book and this is what she had
to say watch this we're facing a really
terrifying attack on abortion in the US
where I live in Northern Ireland and
elsewhere in the past the strategies
that our side has tended to use have
included a kind of seeding of ground to
our enemies we tend to say that abortion
is indeed very bad but or we say luckily
it's not killing luckily it's just a
health care right we have very little to
lose at the moment when it comes to
abortion and I'm interested in winning
radically and I wonder if we could think
about defending abortion as a right to
stop doing gestational work abortion is
in my opinion and I recognize how
controversial this is a form of killing
it is a form of killing that we need to
be able to defend I am NOT interested in
where a human life starts to exist
I see the forms of making and unmaking
each other as sort of continuous
processes the other end of the spectrum
is the process of learning how to die
well and hold each other and let each
other go
at the end of our lives as well as at
the beginning but looking at the biology
of this kind of Hema Coryell pleasent
ation helps me think about the violence
that innocently a fetus meets out visa
vie urges data and that violence is is
an unacceptable violence for someone who
doesn't want to do gestational work
the violence that that just data meets
out to essentially go on strike or exit
that that workplace is an acceptable
violence okay so there you go
and and that's really that's that's good
it's good that she says this I mean
because it's honest and this is the one
honest coherent pro-abortion argument
it's the one pro-abortion argument that
makes sense now
it's deranged its it's morally deranged
it's horrifying its ghastly but it
doesn't it makes sense for a certain
perspective you know if you're coming
from the from from a from an entirely
selfish perspective where you know you
don't care about morality you don't care
about other people and you're just
living for yourself from that
perspective then yeah that makes sense
sure she says and and you know she she
admits she says abortion is killing she
says she doesn't care when life begins
maybe life begins in the womb she's
willing to concede that she says that
the unborn life is innocent you know she
uses the word innocent in there so she
surrenders all that ground she stops
disputing any of that and she says that
she thinks pro-abortion people shouldn't
dispute any of that and and she says
yeah but a woman should still be able to
commit this act of violence against the
innocent because they shouldn't have to
be pregnant if they don't want to be and
I think another even more simple way of
putting that is I should be able to get
an abortion because I want to that
really is the argument putting
everything else aside personhood the
humanity of the unborn
you know rape and incest exceptions and
just putting all that to the side the
fundamental argument that this woman is
presenting
is I want to do it and so I should be
able to do it that's that's that's
really what it comes down to and it is
as I say the the only coherent
pro-abortion argument because it avoids
making any scientifically disprovable
claims most pro-abortion arguments you
hear can be scientifically disproven in
five seconds like we can prove
scientifically that an unborn that a
quote unquote fetus is a human being
that's very easy to prove just pick up
any biology textbook and you can
demonstrate that fact but here is its
side steps all of that and for someone
to say well I should be able to do it
because I want to that's that's not a
scientific claim at all so you can't use
science against that now you're getting
into morality and philosophy and all of
that so I for one am glad that this
woman put this out there I'm happy when
pro-abortion people make this argument
because it is honest and it lays bare
the pro-abortion position
it shows you what what really lies at
the bottom of it which is just absolute
uncompromising selfishness and what I
would encourage you know any any
pro-abortion person who watches that
video or hears that footage and just
kind of recoils from it and says oh well
wait a second yeah it's good
Eirik oiling but you should stop for a
minute and think you know what what
she's presented there is a coherent
although horrible argument do you can
you think of a of a of a coherent
argument for abortion that is not
horrible because as I said all the
personhood stuff that humanity stuff
that that all that's scientifically
disproven so if you're a pro-abortion
person you know and you hear that and
you recoil maybe that should tell you
something about your position maybe you
should ask yourself whether or not you
actually want to be aligned with people
who profess that philosophy just
something to think about alright let's
go to emails this is from Emily says
dear future supreme overlord I'm a new
listener so I'm not sure if you've ever
if you've already discussed this or not
but I'm wondering about your thoughts on
the big cow movement mgt o/w I think
that's men go their own way movement I
think it's what that stands for
and men who dislike women as a reaction
to feminism I don't personally have a
problem with men doing their own thing
without women however I do have a
problem with men who have had bad
experiences with women who preached to
other more oppression Obul men and boys
telling them that all Western women are
insane and that marriages debt is a
deathtrap I view those people as little
more than a male centric counterpart to
radical feminists while I'm willing to
concede that probably most Western women
are either insane or tainted by insanity
in some way as a Western woman who is a
devout Catholic and not an insane
feminist and who intends to marry one
day I find it unhelpful and unfair that
women such as myself get lumped in with
the crazies by these men as they don't
seem to think that sane women actually
exist also when you ascend to your
rightful place as ruler of the solar
system would a gift of a decorative
pillow make you more or less likely to
grant me a quick death
hi Emily well I
you already know the answer to that last
question and so I don't think I need to
spend any time on that
as for the the MIG tau movement I don't
know if that's actually what they call
themselves MIG tau I think it I agree
with you I think it makes the same
mistakes that feminism makes feminism
especially the feminism of the last 100
years or so
well okay feminism of the last maybe
that's going a little too far a feminism
of the last 50 years or so has been
almost completely anti family and anti
man with really no redeeming qualities
whatsoever feminism of the last 50 years
pretty much ever since feminism really
invested itself in in arguing for
abortion and when abortion became kind
of the central the centerpiece of
feminism now you go back a hundred years
and you'll find that feminists did have
some legitimate gripes certainly you
know advocating for the vote for women
okay that was a legitimate point
feminism a hundred years ago had some
had other legitimate points to make but
even then I think and this is a mistake
that that I that conservatives will make
where they say that yeah you know
feminism used to be a good thing but it
became perverted over time and and now
it's not so good I think that feminism
if you if you really research it and you
read into it and you read what the kind
of original feminists actually had to
say you'll find that feminism has always
been anti family and anti-men and also
anti Christian by the way it's always
been that way it just so happened that
one hundred years ago or one hundred and
ten years ago they had it's an anti
family and anti man but they act but
they were fighting for some good things
as well now they're not fighting for
anything good it's just anti-family anti
men I think it's it's the same thing
with the men's rights people the you
know men go their own way the male
feminists whatever you want to call them
they are anti family because they're
anti marriage and you can't have a
stable healthy family without marriage
so they're anti family and and they're
anti woman to answer the anti man
position of feminists now they do have
some legitimate points namely their
criticisms of feminism are oftentimes
correct the only problem is as you point
out they're exhibiting the exact same
pitfalls just from the opposite
direction so they aren't really an
answer to feminists because they are
feminists basically they are just
bizarro world feminists I think a real
answer to feminism is a movement that is
pro-family pro-marriage and not anti
either gender a movement that recognizes
the complementary nature of the sexes
and seeks to build up men and build up
women and and encourage happy and
healthy marriages and Families I mean
that's how you you combat feminism in my
view not by just being you know anti
woman in general and of course it's just
it's just not true that all Western
women are crazy feminists anymore than
it's true that all men are you know are
sexually harassing jerks like feminists
like to paint them I mean both of those
stereotypes are completely false and
ridiculous and all you have to do is
just go out there and meet people and
you'll discover that you know if a
feminist would just go out and actually
meet men and get to know them they would
see that the way they paint men is
incorrect and same for these male
feminist types I mean I know plenty of
women my wife included who are not only
not feminists but are more
anti-feminists than I am you know all
right this is from
dave says Matt I can relate to what
you're going through I tore my Achilles
about a week before you I admire the
fact you've been able to joke about it
so much honestly I've been extremely
depressed about it
can't go anywhere can't do anything
can't drive I'm usually a very active
person so this has been devastating my
question for you is what are you doing
to pass the time how are you using all
the down time that's the hardest part
for me yes it was the most it was the
most physically painful thing I ever
felt when it happened and it hurt pretty
bad after the surgery but the pain is
nothing compared to the boredom and the
unwelcome change to my lifestyle Dave I
feel like we should start a support
group maybe a support group for giimpse
giimpse Anonymous although I guess I'm
not very anonymous so it doesn't really
it doesn't really work
it is tough but don't let my joking fool
you I am also equally as depressed by
the fact that all I can do is basically
lay around the house
it is pretty torturous especially in the
summer you know I just look outside and
the birds are chirping and it's a
beautiful day and Here I am it is it's
pretty bad but you know we should we
should also remember that it's this is
temporary for us there are a lot of
people who have permanent disabilities
and I'm sure they look at us whining
about you know of a few months of
downtime and they just roll their eyes
so as far as what I'm doing to pass the
time well I personally I can't sit for
hours and watch TV I just I can't do it
much less could I sit for weeks and
watch TV I just I don't like TV that
much it gets boring so what I decided
was I want to take a subject and just
learn everything I can about that
subject while I'm laying around you know
just read a bunch of books and because I
don't know why not I mean if I if I
can't exercise physically at least I can
use my brain and so as someone who's
interested in the Civil War I decided
that I'm just gonna binge read Civil War
book so I've got a stack of Civil War
books just working my way through them
and you know because but I don't know
it's something to do and at least I can
learn something in the meantime so maybe
that would be my suggestion is pick it
pick a topic
any topic really and get a bunch of
books about it and just read about that
topic and then by the time you're you
know you're you're physically healthy
again you'll be you'll be an expert on
that topic which which I think actually
even if you don't have a torn Achilles
maybe that's good it but maybe we could
all do that even regardless of our of
our health situation just I think it's a
good a good thing to do just every once
in a while pick some topic and learn
everything you can about it
just for the sake of learning about it
not because you're gonna use the
information not because it's gonna help
you with your job or whatever but just
to know it just for the sake of knowing
all right this is from Lee says yo Matt
heard one of your monologues on beards
recently and a couple of questions
popped into my head
is there a moral case to be made for
beards for beard slash not shaving does
this fall under the category of vanity
is it emasculating or kowtow into female
prejudices to shave
I think CS Lewis or Chester didn't
mention this somewhere on the other hand
is the current relative popularity of
beards tied into a subconscious
knowledge of the loss of real
masculinity and a superficial attempt to
retrieve it well first of all CS Lewis I
think really his only flaw was that he
had no facial hair so I don't think he
said that which is really a tragedy that
he didn't have a facial hair yeah I
think you you certainly could argue that
it is immoral to be clean-shaven
it's definitely problematic ethically
speaking no question about that is it a
sin is it is it will you go to hell you
know for instance for for being
clean-shaven this is something that
theologians can debate I would tend to
say yes probably and my reason for that
is very simple WWJD what would Jesus do
well we know based on all the all the
paintings that we see that Jesus had a
beard also he was an Orthodox Jew so
that's a
the reason why he had a beard and so you
know I mean Jesus had a beard yet
you as a man shave your beard so you're
saying that what you are better than
Jesus I mean it's just I put it this way
I would not want to approach the pearly
gates with with with a baby face I would
it's not a risk that I would want to
take so that's all that's all I'll say
about that let's get to one more email
this is from LC here we have time for
this one I guess we'll say this why I
got a good email about euthanasia which
has been back in the news and but that's
going to be kind of a long answer so I
think we'll save that one Bri I got your
email and I'll save it for tomorrow but
thanks everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show the New York
Times a former newspaper launched a
full-on attack on conservative voices on
YouTube over the weekend essentially
giving cover to YouTube's plan to de
platino
in other words conservatives or anyone
the New York Times a former newspaper
thinks is unacceptable well if we're
going to start censoring haters I say we
start with the people who support baby
killing and spine on presidential
candidates like the New York Times a
former newspaper now let's let them talk
to that's on the Andrew Clavin show
I'm Andrew Clavin